[Música]
encuentro del presidente en la casa
blanca el mandatario estadounidense Joe
biden recibió a su homólogo colombiano
Gustavo Petro los temas que discutieron
fueron Venezuela la política antidrogas
y la crisis climática
Ucrania y Rusia intentan Buscar alianzas
en América Latina el presidente
ucraniano
habló en la cámara de diputados de
México Mientras que el canciller ruso
sergei cerró su gira por el continente
en Cuba
a propósito del día internacional de la
marihuana la industria cannábica de
Estados Unidos enfrenta un exceso de
oferta que contrasta con la limitación
Interestatal del uso del Cannabis les
contaremos los detalles
bienvenidos aquí comienzan las noticias
que France 24 le dedica a América yo soy
María Clara calle iniciamos en Estados
Unidos por primera vez desde que es
presidente del líder colombiano Gustavo
Petro viajó a este país el jueves se
reunió con su homólogo Joe biden y
hablaron de los temas que generan más
tensión entre ambos ellos discrepan en
la política antidrogas y en el trato que
se le debe dar a Venezuela en la región
Aunque coinciden en sus políticas para
hacerle frente a la crisis ambiental
Venezuela migración narcotráfico y medio
ambiente todos temas centrales del
esperado encuentro entre los presidentes
de Estados Unidos y Colombia con
respecto a las sanciones a Venezuela
Gustavo Petro resaltó la hoja de ruta
para el levantamiento de las penalidades
no se condicionó digamos quedó planteado
sobre la mesa
una estrategia que
es hacer primero elecciones y después
levantar sanciones o
paulatinamente en la medida en que se va
cumpliendo una agenda una agenda
electoral se vaya también paralelamente
levantando progresivamente sanciones
Petro reaccionó además a la pregunta
sobre una posible mediación entre
Miraflores y la Casa Blanca No yo no soy
mediador biden agradeció a su homólogo
latinoamericano Por recibir a miles de
migrantes venezolanos en Colombia
minutos antes en el despacho oval
intercambiaron un tema siempre candente
entre ambos países el narcotráfico Petro
quien afirma que la guerra contra las
drogas ha fracasado pidió lanchas
embarcaciones y drones para frenar el
flujo de drogas Washington insiste en la
erradicación forzada de los cultivos
pues son más de 200.000 las hectáreas
sembradas en Colombia en 2021 según
Naciones Unidas la protección del medio
ambiente no quedó fuera de la reunión
juntos Colombia y Estados Unidos están
liderando un esfuerzo para enfrentar el
cambio climático he estado trabajando
durante mucho tiempo hacemos lo correcto
para hacer un compromiso de 500 mil
millones de dólares para lidiar con la
preservación de la amazonía
Gustavo Petro intercambió con baile en
sus planes sobre su proyecto de paz
total un proceso que conlleva el
levantamiento de órdenes de captura a
líderes Rebeldes y criminales buscados
por Estados Unidos
el expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo
intentó una vez más frenar su
extradición hacia su país natal el
jueves un jueves Federal de Washington
denegó la más reciente moción de
emergencia que presentó el mandatario
para quedarse en Estados Unidos el
viernes se debe entregar a las
autoridades Aunque Toledo insiste en que
tiene un mal estado de salud y que teme
que algo le suceda en Perú donde lo
acusan de corrupción por el caso
odebrecht nuestro corresponsal Francisco
Zacarías tiene los detalles desde Lima
el expresidente Alejandro Toledo le ha
exigido a la justicia peruana que no
permita su muerte en la cárcel y que le
deje luchar con argumentos a Toledo no
le queda más que entregarse agentes
federales para ser retenido y
extraditado a Perú horas antes el
tribunal del distrito de Columbia en los
Estados Unidos rechazó una moción de
emergencia presentada por Abogados del
ex mandatario peruano que pretendía
frenar la orden de detención sentenciada
por el juez de California Thomas Gibson
Alejandro Toledo ha sido notificado para
entregarse este viernes a las nueve de
la mañana en la sede del tribunal del
distrito Norte de California José Tello
ministro de justicia de Perú anunció que
un equipo de la oficina de cooperación
internacional apoyado por la Interpol y
la cancillería viajará a California para
recibir al ex gobernante peruano y
retornar al país en el más corto plazo
al respecto elian Card esposa de
Alejandro Toledo sostuvo que a su
criterio no existiría un juicio justo
para el ex mandatario
porque sostiene que en Perú habrían
decidido armar una farsa carp también
confirmó que Toledo padece de Cáncer y
que su Retorno a Perú complicaría su
salud Alejandro Toledo deberá responder
a la justicia peruana por un caso de
corrupción en el que la fiscalía lo
acusa de recibir sobornos de 35 millones
de dólares de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht
el presidente ucraniano
dio un discurso a través de un video
ante la cámara de diputados de México le
hizo un llamado a los congresistas
mexicanos para que respalden a Ucrania
en la Guerra sin embargo el mandatario
Andrés Manuel López Obrador ha sido
reacio en hacerlo bajo el argumento de
la no intervención
recordó que en febrero pidió una cumbre
de países latinoamericanos y como no se
ha hecho le dijo a los diputados que con
la ayuda de México esto sería más rápido
por su parte el canciller ruso sergei
llegó a la Habana como parte de su gira
por latinoamérica allí fue recibido por
las máximas autoridades políticas
cubanas la invasión rusa a Ucrania
estuvo sobre la mesa de conversaciones
Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
un encuentro entre dos viejos aliados el
canciller de Cuba Bruno Rodríguez
parrilla recibió a su homólogo ruso
sergei en el encuentro Se abordó la
cooperación bilateral entre ambas
naciones en un momento delicado para
Rusia que se encuentra inmersa en la
invasión a Ucrania
[Música]
agradecemos el hecho de que desde el
inicio mismo de la operación militar
especial nuestros amigos cubanos el
presidente Díaz canel y otros
representantes de la dirección
delinearon muy claramente su posición y
expresaron plena comprensión en sus
evaluaciones de las razones que llevaron
a la situación actual
Y es que el gobierno cubano desde el
inicio de los enfrentamientos no
respaldó plenamente las acciones de
Moscú Aunque achacó la culpa a su
enemigo político lamentamos
profundamente las pérdidas de Vidas
civiles inocentes en Ucrania el pueblo
cubano ha tenido y tiene una relación
entrañable con el pueblo ucraniano la
historia exigirá responsabilidad al
gobierno de los Estados Unidos por las
consecuencias de la militar
crecientemente ofensiva fuera de las
fronteras de la otan el canciller cubano
abogó por el término del conflicto y
condenó las sanciones contra Rusia
continuaremos abogando por una solución
diplomática seria constructiva y
realista de la actual crisis en Europa
por medios pacíficos que garantiza la
seguridad y soberanía de todos así como
la paz la estabilidad y la seguridad
regional e internacional
fue recibido además por el presidente
cubano Miguel Díaz canel y Raúl Castro
Cuba fue la última parada del canciller
ruso después de una gira que también lo
llevó a Brasil Venezuela y Nicaragua
el 20 de abril es el Día Internacional
de la marihuana a propósito de la fecha
en France 24 les presentamos un informe
sobre el problema que enfrenta la
industria cannábica en Estados Unidos
donde el exceso de oferta se enfrenta a
la limitación Interestatal del uso del
Cannabis los cultivadores pierden el
excedente y por eso le piden al
presidente Joe biden que permita el
comercio de marihuana entre los estados
donde ya han regulado su uso
las granjas de cannabis son habituales
en la costa oeste de Estados Unidos esta
en Washington es una de las más de mil
que existen solo en este estado junto
con Colorado Washington fue el primer
estado en legalizar la marihuana en el
país Oregón hizo lo propio tres años
después durante un tiempo los
cultivadores de marihuana Tuvieron mucho
éxito pero ahora ven como su negocio se
esfuma en medio de un mercado
sobresaturado Isaac Foster es el
fundador de un mercado de Cannabis en
Portland
tener claro cómo funcionan sus
debilidades
el exceso de oferta Yo diría que es la
palabra clave para definir el mercado de
Cannabis en Oregón este estado es un
maravilloso experimento porque a
diferencia de otros estados tenía un
sistema de licencias básicamente
ilimitadas que alentó a un gran número
de personas a cultivar
la imposibilidad de vender cualquier
excedente es otro problema se queda
Atrapado dentro de las fronteras del
Estado debido a la prohibición Federal
de la marihuana algunos mantienen la
esperanza de que la administración del
presidente Joe biden apruebe el comercio
de marihuana entre los estados que la
han regulado estamos aquí sentados en
una especie de ralentí de nuestra
capacidad Si se quiere a la espera de
que nuestras leyes cambien para que
podamos posicionarnos para jugar Ya
sabes para participar en el mercado en
general pero algunos cultivadores no
encuentran solución a la vista y se las
arreglan mientras pueden
Y sí la estoy vendiendo ahora voy a
tener pérdidas pero ya sabes tienes que
saber cuando hay pérdida
21 estados ya han legalizado el uso
recreativo del Cannabis en el país las
ventas combinadas de cannabis medicinal
y recreativo en Estados Unidos podrían
alcanzar los
33.600 millones de dólares a final de
2023 y más de 50.000 millones en solo
cinco años
hasta aquí las noticias pueden consultar
más en nuestra página France 24.com
[Música]